for me water is life people can survive
without food for three weeks but we are
water we cannot survive for even three
days namaste my name is ash oh god girl
i'm the inventor of UV water works two
billion people in the world don't have
access to safe drinking water the death
toll mostly children below h5 from
diarrheal disease from waterborne
disease is two million deaths per year
the UV what about this machine this
infects water very very inexpensively
water goes into the device gets
irradiated with UV light and comes out
from here free of active or alive
pathogens so it is as simple as possible
the product is now serving more than a
million people clean water has a
dramatic effect on the local economy
children don't miss school anymore it
has impact on hunger because when people
lose their income or into diarrheal
disease the immediate effect for these
people is to have hunger at home
berkeley the terrific place for an
inventor you'll need people at a water
cooler who are the world's best experts
a number of topics just in one day
you'll meet 20 of these people any idiot
can make something very complicated it's
very difficult to make something very
simple
you